what is going on everybody welcome back
to the cosmic wonder I'm Warren Thompson
and today we have some exciting news
about the Fantastic Four now it looks
like the casting for Mr Fantastic and
the invisible woman that we thought had
been locked down is no longer the case
it was almost a done deal that Adam
Driver would play Reed Richards aka Mr
Fantastic and that Margot Robbie would
play Sue storm AKA The Invisible Woman
of the Fantastic Four but it seems like
that is no longer the case and that they
are out it doesn't mean they can't come
back but we have heard that they are no
longer in negotiations with Marvel
Studios to play these characters which
means the roles of Sue storm and Reed
Richards are still open now we haven't
really heard much about the Human Torch
or the thing so Paul muscal and David
Diggs still could very much be in the
running in fact we've heard David Diggs
is still in talks with Marvel Studios to
play the thing but there have been talks
about one other person that Marvel
Studios could want to play the thing and
they have wanted to talk to him about
playing a character in the MCU in the
past as well and it looks like Ryan
Gosling could be joining the MCU now we
know Kevin feige has said that he is
very much open to Ryan Gosling joining
the MCU in fact he wants him to join the
MCU of course if the part is right now
the only question is if he joins the
Fantastic Four which part is he going to
play we're gonna break all of this down
in this video including who is most
likely our new Sue storm and if you're
new be sure to subscribe so you don't
miss out on any of the latest MCU news
and if you subscribe and leave a comment
you're automatically entered in our
giveaway for a chance to win an Xbox
series X A PS5 some Marvel Legends items
or some DC items the winner gets to pick
one item and we pick a winner at the end
of each month so let's first start off
with our invisible woman because after
Margot Robbie supposedly passed on the
deal to play Sue Storm Marvel apparently
went back to pretty much their second
person that they wanted to play Sue
storm actually I should should say third
person because we have had reports from
some insiders that Emma Stone was
reportedly offered the role of Sue storm
some time ago but turned it down the
report was that she turned it down
because there wasn't enough money there
and that seems to be kind of a common
theme right now for the two castings of
Reed Richards and Sue storm money
apparently Emma Stone turned down the
role because of money and that seems to
be the case for Adam Driver and Margot
Robbie as well they wanted more money
but we heard that others have been in
the role for Sue storm for a pretty long
time that Marvel has had their eye on
Jody Comer and Vanessa Kirby and
according to three different insiders
Daniel rpk Grace Randolph and John
campia they have all heard that Vanessa
Kirby has been offered the role of Sue
storm officially now I love Vanessa
Kirby she is a great actress and she has
been in many big films however of course
she is not at the level of Margot Robbie
because very few are so so having said
that Marvel Studios won't have to pair
as much if Adam Driver and Margot Robbie
wanted 20 million then maybe Vanessa
Kirby wants 15 million or 12 million
again I love her but that's just how it
is so the money problem that got in the
way with Emma Stone being Sue storm and
with Margot Robbie being Sue storm
probably isn't that much of a problem
with Vanessa Kirby however hopefully her
Landing this role will give her that
problem in the future and based off of
what we've heard Margot Robbie really is
out however Insider Casey Walsh has
recently implied that Adam Driver is
still on the table they are just talking
about the money still in response to
some tweets stating that Adam Driver
came back to the table as Mr Fantastic
he replied with it's a pay dispute and
the SAG strike doesn't help and Adam
Driver has worked with Disney before of
course Star Wars he is kylo Ren so he's
worked with Disney for a very long time
so they're probably trying to be
accommodating towards him but at the
same time they do have a budget however
I will say Vanessa Kirby if she did
indeed accept the role of Sue storm we
heard it's been offered to her
officially but we don't know if she's
accepted it yet but if she does and we
assume that she's not going to get paid
as much as Margot Robbie wanted then
that opens up a little bit more money to
pay Adam Driver and perhaps that's why
Adam Driver is still on the table and
Marvel Studios apparently wants a big
name actor to come in to play one of the
roles of the Fantastic Four members
somebody on Twitter pointed out the fact
that Ryan Gosling would make a great
Booster Gold which is an upcoming
project and character that DC Studios is
currently working on however Insider
sinistelth stated he might be a little
occupied somewhere else in which then
Insider Casey Walsh responded to that
tweet stating one of the reasons they
are having trouble locking down the
Fantastic forecast the MCU is trying to
pull in big name Stars so the
preoccupation mentioned the fact that
Ryan Gosling might be too preoccupied to
go play Booster Gold for DC is because
he could be playing a huge role over at
Marvel Studios for the Fantastic Four
now nobody has specifically said which
character of the Fantastic Four he would
be playing but we can assume it would be
Mr Fantastic or the Human Torch and I'm
leaning more towards Mr Fantastic Reed
Richards is the leader of the Fantastic
Four and he's also a leader in general
when it comes to Marvel and superheroes
and consistently throughout Marvel
history in the comics he has been cited
as the most intelligent person alive
sometimes even quoting him as the most
intelligent being in general so rest
assured are Mr Fantastic are Reed
Richards isn't just going to be a one
and done we're not just going to have
one Fantastic Four movie and that's it
sorry John Krasinski but at least we did
get to see it once as Mr Fantastic but
Ryan Gosling is more than likely talking
to Marvel Studios about playing Mr
Fantastic this would be a role that he
would be interested in and right now
he's got a lot of hype behind his name
Barbie is about to release on July 21st
and what's interesting about that is his
co-star for that film Barbie herself is
Margot Robbie who apparently turned down
the role of Sue storm however we do know
that Ryan Gosling has actually met with
Marvel Studios before but Kevin feige
meets with a lot of people about
possible future roles and Kevin feige
has stated before that sometimes he
meets with actors multiple times to talk
about multiple different roles but they
ultimately never end up deciding on a
roll and that actor never gets cast for
a part in the MCU it depends on the fit
and Jake Gyllenhaal said that he met
with Marvel Studios many times about
many different characters until they
finally agreed Mysterio was a perfect
fit for him then they killed him off in
one movie but we know that Ryan has met
with Marvel Studios and we know that he
was also up for the role of Nova
According to some insiders but perhaps
the reports were wrong maybe he was up
for Reed Richards or maybe he was up for
Nova but now that Reed Richards isn't
locked down Marvel Studios going wait
maybe actually Ryan could play Mr
Fantastic he's a huge name right now and
he would probably need a little bit more
money but again if vanessa Kirby a sue
storm a little money just opened up for
him so Ryan Gosling could go on to be
our Mr Fantastic of the MCU and as I
mentioned we've recently heard a little
rumor going around that Marvel Studios
in the past was actually looking at
David Diggs and Nick Kroll for Moon
Knight two Jewish actors and that's what
they want for the thing the thing is
Jewish in the comics so they want a
Jewish actor to play him so Nick Kroll's
name could be thrown out there for the
thing especially if they want to add
that comedic aspect to the Fantastic
Four team him and Johnny typically bring
the humor so that's not a confirmation
by any means but just a rumor that's
going on right now that Marvel Studios
might be considering Nick Kroll again
for the role of the thing however it
does seem like the V Diggs might be
locking down that role pretty soon so as
of right now our potential fantastic
forecast is either Ryan Gosling or Adam
Driver as Mr Fantastic Vanessa Kirby
seems to be the best bet right now for
Sue storm considering the fact that
Marvel Studios has officially offered
her the role so if she accepts it she's
in all we've heard really about the
Human Torch so far is about Paul muscal
possibly getting the role and right now
the things front runner is David Dix so
let us know what you think about this so
far who would you like to play these
roles let us know in the comments down
below don't forget to like the video and
subscribe so you can enter our giveaway
you can also follow us on Instagram and
Twitter and if you want to support the
channel further you can check out our
patreon our website or our Discord
server as always thank you all so much
for watching woof woof
ha